videos like these capture the hundreds
of unidentified aerial phenomena or UAP
sightings each year
now an independent team formed by NASA
is addressing how and why it's
investigating the incidents the presence
of uaps raises concerns about the safety
of our skies in the group's first public
meeting Wednesday experts stress the
need for more high quality observations
to uncover the truth in fact if I were
to summarize
in one line what I feel we've learned
it's we need high quality data the panel
said stigmas leads to people being
reluctant to report sightings and
harassment for scientists investigating
them but many events that are studied
can be explained in the environment that
we fly in space or you know an
atmospheric flight very very conducive
to optical illusions